forty-eight hours of nonfiction books
Saturday through Monday morning on book
TV the latest book by Douglas Brinkley
pictured here is about civil rights
figure Rosa Parks it chronicles her life
from her childhood education to her
continued support of civil liberties up
next mr. Brinkley talks about his work
as part of our weekly look at biography
books it's a little over an hour
[Applause]
see this is such a wonderful group thank
you so much and thank you Doug thank you
for bringing us all together
I would like mrs. parks all of her
family that is here all of all of her
blood family first to stand we're all
her family but all of her blood family
that has come to join us would you all
stand please
[Applause]
and you saw a part of her church family
earlier but with other members of her
church family that are scattered
throughout would you please stand we
thank you so much there are everyone
here is special congressman Conyers
office whom she worked for for many many
years the congressman is in Washington
taking care of the business of the
United States but his right arm and
right hand who was his chief of staff
mr. ray Plowden and his wife is here mr.
Lawton would you please stand
[Applause]
we are too honored to have dr. grace
Boggs here who is a noted author and
lecturer and activists herself dr. box
would you please stand that she is the
closest contemporary I'm not going to
introduce everybody because Judge Keith
is going to help with introducing others
and Doug is going to help with
introducing people also and then I will
come back and introduce more but I want
to get into the lecture right now which
is what you all came to hear this man
has truly accomplished a great feat that
he has in fact put more history about
this lady in one place than any other
individual known to date so we thank you
we appreciate you now many of us in this
room contributed to this book her pastor
mr. Eddie
Reverend Eddie Robinson who is not here
with us this evening but he shared quite
a bit of time with dr. Brinkley and many
of her family members who are here
shared a lot of time with him Institute
family the congressman's office and many
of us were just very eager to
participate and this historic event
because we all know about the bus
incident but where's the rest of the
story
and dr. Brinkley has attempted to bring
to us a part of the rest of the story
now I know those of us who have read the
book and looked through it that we know
that
everything is not quite on point but
we're gonna help him with that so that
when the sequel is written that we're
going to cover those things but I want
you to know that just imagine a
historian a reporter to be as sensitive
as this individual has been and writing
down and authorized biography he has
talked with mrs. parks he has had the
dear honor of sitting at her feet and
speaking with her and she has truly
enjoyed his writings she mostly enjoys
what he has said about Raymond all the
good things that he has said about
Raymond there's some things that she
said about Raymond that she frowned on
but he has tried to bring forth the
panoramic view and for that we are truly
truly grateful dr. Franklin
[Applause]
well good evening and thank you for
coming it's great to see you all
there's so many people I consider new
friends that I've met along the trail of
writing this book that are here and at
one juncture when at the end of my
lecture I'm gonna single out some people
I particularly like to thank but also
the family of mrs. Parkes I'd like to
just you to introduce yourselves to the
rest of the people this is a c-span
broadcast also so it gives us a chance
to tell the story to Rosa Parks to all
sorts of people in America which was my
original intention but before I begin
I'd be remiss not to thank you Layne
steel for just putting this evening
together and along with Willis Edwards
and many other people at the the Rose
and Raymond parks Institute for self
development here in Detroit which does
so much good work and I just thank you
so much for allowing me as you said the
privilege to to enter this world when I
had finished my manuscript and I was
ready to get a publication going I had a
couple of things that had me terrified
as an author and one that as I promised
I'd show it to Elaine Steele and mrs.
parks they were gonna read the book not
so they could make me change my opinions
but for to fact-check some things and
make sure it was accurate and I'll never
forget the morning I was traveling I was
actually in Shreveport Louisiana and my
office had told me they a couple days
after I sent the manuscript there was a
call at something like 7:00 a.m. in the
morning on my box and another one at
around 8 a.m. then a third call and I
said oh no they don't like the book and
I and just the opposite they found some
things that they thought were inaccurate
and I was so pleased to to correct but
the open spirit that mrs. Parkes and
Elaine Steele and Willis Edwards have
have given me to do this content this
book I'm just truly truly appreciative
also somebody who's worked with mrs.
Parks Gregory Reed who was a lawyer when
I had sent him a copy of the manuscript
he gave me a very high compliment
because he called back and he said you
know I really enjoyed it that you did a
really good job I couldn't tell you were
white when you
said you were fair your I took that as a
compliment in a great compliment because
in many ways I was entering the whole
world of african-american history the
civil rights movement
I wasn't born in 1955 and this is Parks
was arrested I was and just an infant at
the time of dr. King's that you know
it's march on Washington speech by the
time of his assassination I barely have
any recall even of that so for me this
is all true history where many of you
have lived it in a much more active and
very real way you go to Montgomery
Alabama and you can go talk to the
people who walk for 381 days they're all
over there working in restaurants and
hospitals or in retirement centers or
you can meet them in churches they all
walked 381 days I've interviewed many of
the women of the bus boycott and then
I'd also like to invite all of you
December 1st or we think but it will be
what you'll be hearing about they are
opening a museum for mrs. parks finally
in Montgomery at the very spot of her
bus arrest it's going to be a museum in
library
[Applause]
well when I began the idea of writing a
biography on mrs. parks came to me when
I teach a course that I bring some
inner-city high school students I called
the Magic Bus and a I bring ten high
school teachers and 20 high school
students from New Orleans so we do two
and a half weeks civil rights tours
through the South we visit Selma we
march across the Edmund Pettus Bridge we
go to the Lorraine Motel where dr. King
was slain in Memphis we meet with people
like Julian Bond and John Lewis and the
like but the students love the most as
Rosa Parks States something about her
story and about what they've learned
about her fascinates them to no end
yet when we would go to Montgomery there
really wasn't a memorial for Rosa Parks
there's one great one I think the best
Monument and all of Alabama's where you
see Rosa Parks Avenue which used to be
Cleveland Avenue where she lived at
Cleveland courts and now intersects
Jefferson Davis Boulevard and and that's
fun to look at that sign and realize the
progress that has been made in civil
rights to realize that there are
integrated restaurants and integrated
swimming pools and there have been
voting rights accident yet on that same
place just a couple blocks away I
visited the very apartment housing
project and mrs. parks lived in in the
1950s it was built in 1941 and I've
knocked there they think they thought I
was a cop who's come around with the pad
riding around I wanted the dimensions of
her door
and I wanted to know how many steps in
the evening she had to climb after being
a seamstress all day to go to her
bedroom upstairs and I want to know you
know what did her kitchen look like and
I met a woman there named Cynthia Wilson
who lives today in mrs. Parkes very
apartment and you know they're they
cancelled the bus service in Montgomery
on that very place if you live in
Cleveland courts you can't get on a bus
to go where she works in a hospital
downtown due to a what some people would
call a kind of Tale of Two Cities in
Montgomery a wealthier West a Montgomery
and a poor East Montgomery I don't want
to get into that too much now any
question and answer session we can but
in other words there's a long ways to go
still as you all know
in the civil rights movement it hasn't
ended yet phase one may have closed down
and we may have been stalling here a
little bit on phase two but it's gonna
click in sometime soon well to begin my
journey in mrs. parks I went to Alabama
and I visited Tuskegee Institute where
she was born in 1913 and the historian
Henry Louis Gates reminds us that Rosa
Parks was born in 1913 in a month later
Harriet Tubman died and as Professor
gates who runs the W EB the Boyce Center
at Harvard says it's as if a baton was
passed that from if you spend an evening
today in Detroit with mrs. parks you
goes all the way back from that change
to Harriet Tubman you get this wave of
American history and it gives you just
chills to think about the freedom
movement and also I have to say what
I've learned quickly about the
researching this book is the role of the
AME Church and mrs. parks is life I'm so
thrilled to have you here from st.
Matthew AME Church and you should really
know that it is the a.m. as a scholar
just entering this and studying it the
AME Church is what's given mrs. parks or
inspiration courage determination it's
her faith in God and it started as a
young girl in Alabama and it's never
ended to today as you know she's a
Deaconess at your church and she comes
there and I can't even imagine you know
I mean the the shakes you get I was at a
ceremony that Elaine kindly invited me
to with the Congressional Gold Medal at
H his house he's here and I'll talk
about them both a little more later but
to sit there and hear mrs. Parkes
singing Oh freedom Oh freedom Oh freedom
over me and before obviously chills just
hit you when you hear just realize what
she's gone through and what her life
represents and what she's seen and that
Amy Church is just the it's the heart of
mrs. parks so really thank you so much
for your wonderful music and for being
here I appreciate it immensely
of course the AME churches known as the
freedom church you know Frederick
Douglass was AME Harriet Tubman was AME
Sojourner Truth was AME I didn't know
that before I started this book because
you always hear about the Baptist Church
and he always thinks civil rights
movement was the best other Baptist it
was dr. King and the Southern Christian
Leadership Conference yet the AME Church
is so pivotal in so many ways and I
bring that out in in the book of other
civil rights warriors and activists that
were part of the AME Church well being
born in Tuskegee
in 1913 tells me something very quickly
what up what a historic spot almost
Providence mrs. parks is born in
Tuskegee which the the home of Booker T
Washington and I want to tell you I've
learned to respect Booker T Washington
more doing this book than I previously
had today in 2000 he's written off a
little more than he was generations ago
because of his accommodationist approach
because of some problems that people
scholars feel that he wasn't pushing
enough for political rights for
african-americans in forceful enough way
and all of that is true and w WB Dubois
has sort of taken the mantle of that of
in that earlier part of the century in
the late 19th century but I found out
something very interesting about Booker
T Washington in this book and that is
well miss parks was a young girl she
left Tuskegee but her mother always kept
up from slavery by Booker T Washington
and the Bible handy and it was always
said you know in the sense Rosa and her
brother Sylvester who had moved up here
to Detroit the two of them Rosa when you
grow up you're gonna be able to eat with
Booker T Washington
you're gonna her house is gonna be as
clean as Booker T Washington he was an
inspiration in Alabama back then and
they went to the town of Pine level
Alabama it's a little fly speck town
about 40 miles south of Montgomery and I
went there and I've talked to some
people that remember Rosa Parks when she
was a young girl they're all well into
their 80s today and they have stories
about her as a girl there which is quite
incredible to do incidentally all my
interviews and papers I'll be donating
either to the probably to the Institute
here at some point so some of this
research work I did others could
were from it and fix whatever errors I
may have made and or used that to build
on another book down the line but but
the the from pine level her father had
left mrs. parks and she was really
raised by her mother who was a teacher
and she got a great opportunity to go to
a school in Montgomery called miss
White's school for girls the racism in
Alabama during mrs. parks is is growing
up is beyond the imagination the hatred
that so many whites in Alabama felt for
African Americans is just it's haunting
into skirts disturbing Rosa Parks's
grandfather used to set up at night with
a in a rocking chair with a shotgun
worrying about the KKK you know riding
into town burning their house down
committing terror you know I've read
some places that cities like
Indianapolis had more people in Indiana
had enforced more people in the Klan
than Alabama in the 1920s and that New
Jersey had a big can of Klan population
but that doesn't numbers doesn't take
the terror index nowhere was the Klan
terror index as strong as in that Black
Belt region of the south and of course
Rosa Parks got the opportunity because
her mother was a teacher to go to a
school called miss white school for
girls and this white was a Quaker from
Massachusetts she was Caucasian she was
a pacifist and a teacher and Miss white
at one point because there were no
schools for african-american girls to
get an education
265 african-american young women got
trained and taught at Miss white school
for girls
now basically from today's standards it
looks almost chauvinistic it was home
economics sewing cooking classes but
they but Miss white also taught dignity
and taught that you're as good as
anybody else and I've interviewed a
number of the people who graduated from
Miss whites who knew her including Rosa
Parks
Johnny makar who's in Montgomery and it
had a profound effect on them though
those women and the women who marched in
the Montgomery bus boycott who walked
for 381 days the women of Montgomery
many of the leaders were from Miss white
school for girls and you know where the
money came from that for Miss white
school from girls
I found a document that hadn't been
exposed before in writing this book came
from Booker T Washington who was able to
get some money from the north to funnel
privately into the school miss White's
to keep it going and what Booker T
Washington used to do things like that
and so I learned to appreciate his
behind-the-scenes way of handling
dealing with things so there's a
connection right there between Booker T
Washington and the the Montgomery bus
boycott
well mrs. parks is very bright very
precocious young woman but also very
demure quiet in many ways never wanted
to get in people's way he's always
reading Scripture but had a great sense
of humor and still does have a great
sense of humor and I know that people
here that know her know what a wonderful
sense of humor she has maybe one side of
her the public hasn't had the right
chance to see but believe me it's there
and they a big moment in her life isn't
any young woman's life as when she met
her her love Raymond who the Institute
here in Detroit's named after and
Raymond parks of course Rosen's real
name was Macaulay Rossum Macaulay
she married Raymond parks and became
Rosa Parks and they had a great love and
romance and he was he was somebody that
I think what gets
misunderstood about Raymond is that
because during the bus boycott in 1955
and 56 he has those famous quotes where
he said don't do it Rosa the white folks
are gonna kill you if you challenge this
you know take this to the courts
please don't do it so some off sometimes
they focus on that those words of rain
and caring about his wife safety in a
moment of great stress and the fact that
during the bus boycott he had had a some
emotional breakdown during the time to
make him into some sort of weak man
Raymond was not a weak man Raymond in
the 1930s worked covertly really have
to go underground to work for the
committee to defend the Scottsboro Boys
group of young african-american
teenagers framed of a bright white
raping two white women he raised money
for them held sort of cell meetings in
their house men would have to put guns
down in on the table he was an activist
in the state he was an early believer in
the n-double-a-cp at his barber shop he
was a barber
he had the Pittsburgh courier and the
Chicago Defender in the Amsterdam news
and the african-american papers that
connected black America together in some
ways and he radicalized Rosa Parks in
many ways so did her grandfather so did
the facts he was had educated herself
but it was the team of the two of them
in the 1930s and into the 1940s he
started for a number of reasons getting
a little bit unhappy with aspects of the
n-double a-c-p what while mrs. parks got
more involved with it but one of the
things that people don't realize about
Rosa Parks is that in the 1940s she
worked harder for the n-double-a-cp than
not any woman than any person in the
state of Alabama and she did all sorts
of work for the n-double-a-cp first off
we all know Edie Nixon when the great
civil rights leaders and it was with the
you know was a was a porter the trains
would be gone for weeks at a time to New
York or Chicago
Edie Nixon was Harrison Wofford or used
to be work with John Kennedy and civil
rights call him a Gandhi with guns he'd
be what he was he was the real leader of
among Montgomery and she worked directly
for but she kept his office together she
typed his correspondent she wrote some
of his correspondence she did field work
she would actually go and interview
women that had been raped black women
raped by white men and Alabama which
nobody cared about it was laughed at as
if it's some sort of demented sport and
she would have to come and write the the
documents up about what she encountered
taking the oral history of the of the
woman who was raped
this is mrs. parks
this is mrs. parks who throughout the
1940s starts saying I want the right to
vote I demand the right to vote three
times in the 1940s mrs. parks was denied
the right to bone a man she kept
fighting for it he kept pushing this is
during World War two it wasn't fighting
for custody was anti-american because
she wanted to be a dissident because she
was trying to be radical because it was
if she deserved it I'm an American
citizen as good as anyone else and I
want to boat in fact she wanted to vote
for Eleanor Roosevelt Eleanor Roosevelt
a great deal and Franklin Roosevelt and
wanted to see them elected a third term
and she was constantly denied that
opportunity the eventually she
persevered and we could talk later if
you have any questions about how she was
denied but she kept at it and eventually
got the right to vote this is a woman
you know they would put so many fake
laws and to keep you from voting if you
were black in the South they you could
only register you'd be able to come and
go for a single hour like once every
three months to register it was always
done it will at noontime or at a time
when you had to work and the white
employer wouldn't let you off if you
were black and you said look I'm gonna
go I need an hour or two off to go
register they say you're not getting off
work well you'll be fired you lose your
job if you want to go down there and
then if you took the chance or somehow
found your a way to get there for those
two hours by the time that you'd get
there you would have to wait in a long
line and they move so slow they might
register one african-american for two
hours say well you guys rest you come
back come back to monstermouth torment
torture anything to keep
african-americans from boney that's why
mrs. parks was marched from Selma you
know in the Selma to Montgomery March
and took part of it and believes today
young people have to register and have
to vote we got to stay on a too many
people struggle for that privilege to
forget about it but I wonder found
things that affected me when I was
researching this book was Rosa Parks's
brother Sylvester
because Sylvester and some of his family
is here today and so
Esther was her baby brother she loved
him to no end and he went and served in
the military in the Second World War in
uniform he's part of Tom Brokaw's
greatest generation the greatest
generation of par excellance he was at
Normandy d-day as a medic working with
engineering unit there and later by 45
he was winning Pacific Theater he went
wrote a letter home from dating December
45 after the atomic bomb from Okinawa
this was a real war hero and he saw a
lot of carnage and death which he didn't
talk about I've learned much after his
time in world war two that's not unusual
many World War two veterans didn't talk
about it until recently that was but so
Bester came back to Montgomery in
uniform a proud man and he was ridiculed
by the whites mocked stoned spat on deep
unemployable considered uppity and
essentially he was driven out of out of
town and came to Detroit for employment
with Chrysler and in working here in the
auto industry
hence the connection of Rosa Parks there
was a person loved her baby brother and
that kind of humiliation that he and
other African American servicemen
encountered angered her to no end
because it was supposed to be double
victory right victory over fascism and
then in the Nazis and victory over Jim
Crow they came back fight soldiers of
democracy came back to a no democracy
and not just in the south south gets his
course gets the lion's share of the
finger-pointing but these same African
American soldiers would get off a
gangplank in Boston Harbor and it would
say color and white said apartheid
system that was happening here as a much
of some part tied system is in South
Africa well the other event during the
world war two years had occurred which
is great interest in 1943 mrs. Parkes
one day got on a bus and the driver was
James Blake and she went and sat on the
bus and you know they had that she sat
in the colored section of the
some Blake wanted to have her move and
they had a bit of a disagreement and he
threw her off the bus but which which he
didn't like was way talked to her and
Blake I found out from others and doing
research I mean he always called African
America worst names women the worst
names I don't need to repeat the words
what they would be I do in the book I
don't feel like saying it on a
microphone on a stage but and he was the
mrs. parks that he was mean this was a
mean person and he threw off well it's
that same James Blake who was driving
the bus on December 1 1955 when mrs.
Parks refused to give up her bus seat
some of that civil disobedience was
personal that it was this rudeness of
this driver that's just one small
element but it's an element and I want
you to recognize that well Blake's alive
today and Liz the Montgomery James and I
had asked through Elaine with mrs. parks
if mrs. parks would be willing to take a
photograph with James Blake
I like that healing idea from you know
the new Montgomery mrs. parks and Blake
Hogg and you know because you know
reconciliation you know he's also in his
80s today like mrs. parks mrs. parks
said well of course of course I will of
course I could you know I'm not I can't
bend my blaming him for all of
everything and you know he was in many
ways a pawn in a much bigger game that
particular driver well
that was I didn't we had a mission I
thought I was now I'm gonna find Blake
and interview him and get that photo
beyond the covers of all the papers
around the world well I met mr. Blake
completely and totally unreconstructed I
I've I tried a second time this is no
George Wallace story here of change this
is this is a true man of prejudice
update taking it and I felt in an odd
way he was raving in such a with such
anger I felt sorry for him that he's at
this point in his life
well into his eighties not of this world
for that much longer taken that kind of
hate with them wherever he's going not
being able to let it go I I you know you
you you just have to feel sorry for him
and I'll just let that go as that but
well by the 1950s I'll speed the story
along a little so I don't become go on
too long but of course you all know the
big events Brown burst of pika and what
that event meant in 1954 so things start
speeding up there's an effort all
throughout the south to integrate you
know integrate everything as Fred gray
the lawyer for us parks I want to
integrate everything mrs. parks on the
cutting edge of all that she was
incidentally she wasn't just known in
Alabama all the National people of the
n-double a-c-p knew who Rosa Parks was
because they always said thank God for
Rosa first because she can make sure
keep Edie Nixon in line you know she was
reliable or Nixon sometimes was gone or
you know he had a dis oversized
personality wonderful giant figure a
month and anyway tries anything but bad
about mr. Nixon the opposite but he was
a surly character of mrs. parks would
return the calls or return the letters
or you know and in 1955 as most of you
know a number of key events happened one
was the arrest of Claudette Colvin
Claudette Colvin is alive today lives in
the Bronx and she was a teenager and she
was arrested because in front of Dexter
Avenue Church dr. King's church she
wouldn't give up her bus seat teenage
girls who's eating a candy bar looking
out the window and when they try to make
her move she got an altercation with the
bus driver started screaming in
hysterics
they arrested Colvin Claudette Colvin
and she then was gonna become the new
n-double-a-cp test case well it turned
out first of all if mrs. parks meant
toward Claudette Colvin through her
ordeal she knew her family back from
Pine level Alabama and she took the time
to talk with her and take care of her I
recently spoke to Claudette Colvin who
just thinks the world of Rosa Parks said
how old me how kind she had been to her
even in that period there
um but it didn't work it turned out that
she had been pregnant an unwed teenager
in the most more conservative black
clergy in Montgomery and the more
conservative element in the n-double
a-c-p said we can't make this the test
case so it got ruled out that's one
thing that happened in early 55 that
attempt at integrating the buses of
Montgomery and the failure of Claudette
Colvin case secondly interesting white
couple in Montgomery they were at
franklin roosevelt new dealers virginia
der clifford der and the ders were civil
rights civil liberties advocates and
mrs. parks beacon was a seamstress and
she sometimes did sew dresses and did
great work for the ders but unlike a lot
of these she was not treated in the ders
houses as a domestic worker she was
treated as an equal which is very rare
and the ders to get deserve some credit
for that progressivism which they
brought there they lost all their white
customers or clients as lawyers because
of it well a man named miles Horton and
Highlander Folk School and integrated
school up in Tennessee invited asked
Virginia derv she knew somebody who
could come up to there to study civil
disobedience how do we push the breath
after Brown and 54 how now can we we
fight to win this battle over Jim Crow
and the ders asked Rosa Parks
recommended her and before you know it
Rosa Parks was on a bus up to Mountain
Eagle Tennessee it was there that she
met septum of Clark one of the great
leaders and one of my great finds and
I'd say the thing I'm proudest of in
this book is here cross this way here at
Wayne State University going through a
lot of mrs. parkus papers including
clippings I found 22 pages on yellow
legal pads in pain written in pencil of
the notes she kept at Highlander where
she was taking classes on civil
disobedience and it's fascinating when
[Applause]
when I told when Elaine had me at a at a
dinner in Los Angeles when I mentioned
that to mrs. parks her eyes got big you
found those you're kidding me
and while and also the other great civil
rights leader Ella Baker mrs. parks went
to Jacksonville Florida to meet Ella
Baker in 1946 she was involved with Ella
Baker what you're seeing here is a super
active activist civil rights person into
heading into 55
well after Highlander one other event
occurred in August of 55 when she
returned she had met dr. King once he
was now it's August of 55 he's 26 years
old she's 42 he was nobody heard of dr.
King he was just a young peachfuzz
preacher coming back as everybody knew
his father daddy King but he came down
there and she went to a little group at
a pilgrim insurance company they had it
a small N double AC group and it'd be
about as much as these two rows there
maybe ten people came to hear dr. King
talked about you know the brown decision
and what to do and among those people
were mrs. parks and Johnny makar her
good friend for years who's now still
there in Montgomery and I asked Johnny
makar about you know what did they give
you were you stunned by King and she
said no no no she said Rosa and I said
we just kept elbowing each other saying
isn't he cute
and she said we of course we liked him
but we hadn't who would have known he
was gonna go on to such greatness we
knew he was bright and talented and
handsome and funny and we liked him so
but then that's an August now right at
the same time in 55 you have the murder
of Emmett Till and there are a lot of
young people here and I know most of you
hopefully in your schools by now know
the story of Emmett Till which we should
never forget but in a nutshell he was a
14 year old boy from Chicago who went to
money Mississippi and went into a
mom-and-pop convenient you know a little
store in this little rural Mississippi
town with some other african-american
boys and they dared him to apparently
dared him to wolf-whistle at the white
woman who owned this little shop what
actually occurred something becomes a
little bit unclear
he used to whistle because he had a
stutter and I talked to interviewed
minoo mrs. Bradley but Emmett Till's
mother about this and she said you know
that he they taught him to whistle
because it would help them stop
stuttering whether he wolf whistle door
whether it was a stutter and he whistle
I mean it's up for interpretation but
what isn't up for interpretation is that
when he left there that woman's husband
came in kidnapped fourteen-year-old
Emmett Till along with an in-law and
they took Emmett Till and they they
gouged out his groin they gouged out his
eye they took a bullet and put it into
his head
they bloodied and deformed his body they
tied a 75-pound cotton gin around his
neck and threw him into the Tallahatchie
River where he puts a corpse to a
fourteen-year-old boy and one of the
great things I see willis up there has
his copy of Jet magazine on his lap jet
at that time see this one I'm seeing
says samuel l.jackson is on the cover
they usually have celebrity profiles and
50s maybe Jackie Robinson or Harry
Belafonte well Emmett Till's mother
bless her soul for her courage said
uh-uh I want an open casket in Chicago
at Lanier funeral home I want the whole
world to see what they do to young black
children
Mississippi and a per session of people
came to see that open coffin of Emmett
Till and preachers all over started
talking about it and Jet magazine put
the the mutilated body on the cover of
their magazine and that for mrs. Parkes
was devastating because she loved
children so she never had any children
of her own but she has 13 nieces and
nephews which he loves to death and and
she just loves them so much and she ran
the n-double-a-cp youth group in
Montgomery she once brought a group of
children to the public white library
demanding that they her children at the
Youth Council get to check out books
from the library she challenged the wry
Brer e down there to get because she
wanted her young people to check out the
right books it's not fair that they
couldn't get the right equal learning
through books
well that Emmett Till case just
devastated mrs. parks and it's that
combination now of the brown decision in
the Claudette Colvin case Hearst
building activism you know you could
just feel it and then she's back in it's
August in Montgomery there's no air
conditioning it's hot
she's at the bowels of the Montgomery
fare department store where she worked
in the heat and it's all coming together
that September 55 Adam Clayton Powell
came down and visited there and she met
with him so the big question is on
December 1 1955 was it premeditated did
the n-double-a-cp make mrs. parks do
that or was she know where her feet tire
no it was a lifetime of injustice that
came to a head and there are a lot of
contributing factors I just listed some
I could be listening for you a dozen
more she did not wake up on December 1
at Cleveland courts and say today I'm
gonna get arrested I'm gonna become a
heroic martyr you know she didn't say
that a minute before the driver made her
moves you didn't know what was what was
happening she did another day at work
Christmas lights were on in Montgomery
fare departments or segregated
department store she left work her feet
weren't tired but her arms were cause
she had to use these presses and do
with her arms too much and she had Bruce
itis and so she went to get a heating
pad at Lee cut-rate drug for her arm so
the bus he normally took when she was
waiting for the bus
it got so full and she didn't want to go
crowd in and the back she said I'll go
in a leak get a heating pad buy a few
other toiletries for other items get the
next bus she went in did that
absent-mindedly got on the bus grabbed
her since not noticing Blake was the
driver that wasn't Blake's route usually
that bus at that time he was filling in
for somebody that day and she got on and
sat down in her normal seat next to her
as you know African American sitting
next to you most of you know the story I
won't dwell on it here but you had to
all move if you were at that point you
had to have of course the you know a
white person couldn't send the same row
so of one person if one white person
needed a seat they all had to go and
also there was not a line like white
color the it was up to the discretion of
the driver he they had a little clip-on
sign that said white claw one day he can
move it back three more rows it was a
movable line which created a lot of the
confusion also well and you remember a
lot of the bus drivers used to one bus
driver not long before miss parks were
just shot a black person killed him
because he didn't like what something
that he said oftentimes for sport white
bus drivers would have the
african-americans put their money in the
slot in the front and then you had to
walk to the back because you couldn't
get on the front of the bus and then
they drive off and you had no recourse
key to the frustrate what are you gonna
do call the white police who are you
gonna complain to that's the the
injustice and the indignity that was
occurring so this day mrs. parks staring
out the window and it occurred right
there by the Empire Theatre that's where
Hank Williams the country musician got
his great start she was looking out at
the marquee looking out the window when
he started Blake's shouting in his his
way you know you all give me those seats
get out it you know move slowly and
sheepishly and with some shame the other
african-americans got up and listen mrs.
parks just kept staring out the window
and he started hollering you know I'm
gonna you know you better move you know
if you don't move are you gonna move and
then her her answer was no simple no and
then he said well then I'm gonna arrest
you and here's the key to the Rosa Parks
story I'm gonna arrest you then and she
said you may do that her majestic use of
the word may gave her the ability to be
a protester not a victim yeah you may do
that you know not you can di you you
know if you may it was just the language
simple language and the poise she kept
and at that time her mind just racing
with images of her past and and the
indignities and she would sheet it was
like you could almost see a newsreel
from the middle passage of the slave
ships going on through through you know
the horrors of the african-american
experience here in America racing
through her mind and this was a moment
she just that was it well of course
Blake got flustered he gets on the radio
says this woman won't move what you know
I mean they said arrest her so two cops
came he called the cops they arrested
her talk to the fleet the widows of the
policemen who are alive the police
officers aren't alive anymore
officer Nixon and day and they took her
down the police station they did not
rough her up on the way there they just
kept asking her over and why didn't you
listen to him why didn't you listen to
him but she said that they did not treat
her badly those two policemen they took
her down there but then she was
embarrassed for them because she asked
for a drink of water and one of the said
no those are for whites only they
wouldn't give a woman with parched lips
a sip of water
sort of like Christ swooned and they're
giving him vinegar or something on a and
it's the time of the crucifixion or
something it's as a this denying a
person of thirsty person water but she
went to went to jail and was there for a
couple of hours and finally got to make
her telephone call and got to talk to
Raymond and her mother and I might add
all these years she took care of her
mother and you know
you know she never you know her mother
died here and is buried here in Detroit
as his Sylvester as his Raymond
this is mrs. parks his home in Detroit
and at that point you know she got out
they got bail the et Nixon had the money
the ders didn't have money people
thought the ders did the white couple
they had a Nixon had some cash to get
her out but they wouldn't let him get
her out because he was black so he had
the ders come with him so Virginia
Clifford Durr edy Nixon got her out they
went back to this little place in
Cleveland courts and it's there at that
little apartment that you had the with
historic meeting where they decided to
have the bus boycott where they decided
or not the bus boycott was she agreed to
fight this take it to the Supreme Court
take it as far as it can that this was
it's a watershed mark in American
history in world history that what went
on in that simple housing project that
is not designated with a historic marker
or anything in Montgomery today where
Cynthia Wilson the nurse lives and it is
a shrine site really that kitchen where
that decision was made well you rest of
you know and can read in my book and
other books about the boycott I don't
have the time to go through 381 days and
all the legal maneuverings that occurred
I will say that mrs. parks of course you
have dr. King comes to to great
prominence but I interviewed Nelson
Mandela and of South Africa and Kofi
Annan of Ghana who's now are the the
secretary-general of the United Nations
they both told me when Rosa Parks was
our first great freedom fighter hero
when we heard of her who wrote this
before they even knew who King was mrs.
parks was known her name was known
before dr. King became she had her
picture in the New York Times before dr.
King had his name in the New York Times
so she's really the and a big point I'd
like to make is that is so key about
those 381 days of walking it was when
they arrested Rosa Parks the word spread
you arrested the wrong woman now
because she had done her whole life when
somebody was sick she would come sit at
their bedside and or make him soup when
somebody was had needed a babysitter she
would come and babysit if somebody
needed something sewed for free she's so
she did so many favors he was an angel
and they arrested her and put her in
jail I got they arrested the wrong woman
now if you're gonna have a person to
rally the black community of Montgomery
in America around Rosa Parks was it and
when a lot of people's feet got tired
and weary walking in the rain and in the
heat a lot of moments when that bus
boycott was about to break down through
all sorts of pressures and what kept it
together was the Oratory of King and the
leadership ability of him which is
extraordinary and the spiritual essence
of Rosa Parks
because what person all you had to do
when you want it to break st. Rosa Parks
I'm walking
and the cost she paid was high she lost
her job at Montgomery fare department
store in January her husband lost his
job at Maxwell Air Force Base where he
was a barber at that point there so he
had unemployed group no money coming in
he spent the year she did some traveling
on behalf of the n-double a-c-p but also
manned ham radios also helped people
send her a lot of shoes people all the
world good meaning people thought
everybody needed was shoes because
Montgomery became a walking City and she
would help distribute those out to
people and did constantly involved with
the entire event
unfortunately King star got so big in
Ralph Abernathy Starr got big and things
that by the time the bus boycott finally
ended a year and later over a year later
in December of 1956 the day it ended
nobody asked mrs. parks to come back on
the bus and ride in the front of the bus
everybody they had photo ops with King
and Abernathy and others mrs. parks was
home taking care of her mother when a
look magazine reporter came and said
please mrs. parks you know we want a
picture of you sitting in front of the
bus and was a white reporter and you
know and I'll sit behind you
I'll have my photographer show you're in
front arm and back I'll have my great
picture with a little bit of reluctance
because she never likes to showboat
she's so modest but she I'm thank
goodness she agreed to do this and the
reporter persisted on her to do it she
went and guess who when they make pulled
over a random bus in the middle of the
afternoon who was driving it was Blake
and the in Sheena they didn't say
anything to each other he clammed up and
I'm very quiet and kind of she does not
if he wanted to you know at that point
he had lost the case was lost and the
photo was taken that all of you seen
it's done all over the place and it was
it was staged at that moment
well mrs. parks his time was short as
we've heard and as all of you know
better than I do I'm new to
understanding all this 1957 she moved up
here to Detroit because of endless death
threats now you hear about death threats
right you know I don't know if any of us
can really know what it's like to be
guests getting death threats letters
telephone calls you walk out and people
are threatening you and it's not idle
threats numerous African Americans were
being shot even after the buses got
integrated a pregnant woman was shot by
white Klan was threatening all this
pressure tear terror was faced on
Raymond and Rosa Parks and his nerves
weren't dealing with this very well
Raymond Rosa Parks had an inner strength
to deal with it not all of us can deal
with that kind of death threat and that
was the primary reason she came up to
Detroit to come her family was here
Sylvester was here cousins and this
begin so she made the big move up here
the UAW helped her a little bit when she
came up but to make the journey also and
another factor I found that was also
jealousy in the african-american
community there was a chauvinism some of
the african-american ministers and men
didn't like the fact that everybody
wanted Rosa that you know here she was
the secretary and the the woman and so
suddenly all the press would come we
want to talk to Rosa Parks and they kind
of pushed you know in Abernathy Nixon to
be well here we are
who are you moveaway mrs. parks system
jealousy you know God got involved a
little bit too in Montgomery I don't
want to leave that part out because well
I found out it to be very real Abernathy
who I respect intensely and immensely
unfortunately had that jealousy side to
him which was we all have our
shortcomings and
that was I think his but what really
shocked me is that mrs. Parkes came to
Detroit and cause she's so
internationally known I thought that she
would have been rich I know that sounds
dumb but I would have thought she would
be broke she came here with no money
very little money if it wasn't for her
family so I was here in Sylvester and
others the williamson's and I mean
helping her I mean in helping them get
started here she then started working at
a sewing factory and that's where she
met Elaine Steele many many years ago
Elaine Steele was her seat mate at a
sewing factory where they're making
towels and aprons my primarily aprons
and other things
Stockton's sewing company she was in
high school at caste Tech and it was
working over there and can you imagine
here she knows here's about Rosa Parks
in school and it's all about her
suddenly she goes to get a job in a
sewing factory and her seat mates Rosa
Parks so you wonder why Elaine Steele
has had this long love and relationship
with with Rosa Parks but from that one
incident they of course then reconnected
some some years later and it formed in
recent times the the Institute here
which does so much good work in Detroit
but a little more about quickly and then
I'll wrap this up among her Detroit
years they've been good years and bad
years here
what bad years her mother died her
brother died you know um
her husband died devastating I I know
for a fact when she sits it looks out
over the river now at the boats going by
the Detroit River dumping their cargo
off from the iron ore regions of
northern Michigan and in in the timber
coming down she stares at boats and
passenger boats and just wishes right
wishes her husband Raymond was sitting
there watching the ship's past with her
I think she misses him so intensely and
and there's a great sorrow with that but
there's also during these years she
never stopped working for civil rights
dr. King stayed in constant touch with
her John Conyers told me he never had
been in the Congress if it wasn't for
Rosa Parks because he was a very unknown
person when he first ran in 60
or and she was formed she always
supported people she liked and was doing
some free you know political work for
him and he she got dr. King who made a
rule never to give a political speech
for a candidate he wanted to be above
that kind of fray and except when Rosa
Parks asked him to come on behalf of
John Conyers and dr. King never said no
to mrs. parks and and he came and also
mrs. parks never had any jealousy for
dr. King and he always can feel so
together with her and his love for Rosa
Parks is beyond words in st. for Creta
Scott King today the love for Rosa Parks
is beyond words and so John Conyers got
elected in a large part because King
came and supported him and John Conyers
wisely employed mrs. parks and was able
to get her from working as a full-time
seamstress to work for his congressional
office as you all know here in Detroit
for all those many years and I think we
should thank John Conyers for doing that
[Applause]
and I also found out you know one thing
I thinks of misnomer Time magazine had
Rosa Parks says I have to thank time for
picking hers one of the hundred most
important people of the century they
need to be congratulated for doing that
I think that was a good thing but I want
to chastise them just a little because I
think they call that her as one of the
article one of the children of Gandhi
sort of like dr. King and the truth is
mrs. parks was never as fully devoted to
non-violence in the way that King was
she was to a degree
but I think her philosophy was a more I
will get slapped and turned my cheek
once and I may turn it twice but don't
hit me a third time and so she liked
Malcolm X quite a bit and particularly
after Malcolm X lost some of his more
more you know the the street language
and refined some of his his rhetoric and
in passions after his trip to Mecca and
she was with Malcolm X a week before his
assassination and also you know she as I
said was at the march on Washington with
dr. King and at the Selma to Montgomery
March and it was everywhere
I won't don't have the time to keep
going through all of those but I did
come away with a couple concerns about
her Detroit ears also in later years
that occurred in the 90s and one is a
story of despair to me and one was the
story of liberation and and I'll end
with that I want to despair was when the
story we all know when a burglar broke
into mrs. parks his house and wanted
five dollars from her she's retiring for
the evening and broke into her house one
in the five and then hit her and and and
she got rushed to Detroit receiving
hospital I called she called Lane steel
and they got her to the hospital and you
know that was just a sad moment for
America that the mother the civil rights
movement was beaten in her own home and
and I I remember being pained about
reading that at that point and still
paints us and I've also was a little
concern that I felt and I know there
many dignitaries here from Detroit and
it's not the people that are here that
I'm directing this comment to as an
outsider I felt that Detroit hasn't done
enough for
parks
there is the bullet Rosa Parks Boulevard
which is great important but I think
there needs to be a lot more I'd like to
see right near the new baseball seem a
giant statue of Rosa Parks as big as
those Tigers that are out there in front
[Applause]
but the the liberating part of her
Detroit stories when I got to see some
of the projects with the Institute when
I before I really knew Elaine and her
sister I'm just starting to get in I was
an outsider and as you've heard this is
an iron door not you know every
journalist in the world is trying to
talk to Rosa Parks and I started sending
Elaine and Willis Edwards and and many
others just all my books I wrote CBS I
think at some point they had so many of
my books they were getting sick of it he
said another batch of his worked I just
kept trying to let them know I'm serious
I'm a serious scholar I want to do this
right I'm not just coming for a quick
quote in fleeing and I think that one of
my breakthroughs came when I got to go
up to farming is at Farmington Michigan
where they do an incredible program of
young people let's say Emmett Till is
aged 14 years old that are going to
senior citizens homes or senior centers
and teaching the seniors email and how
to use their computers and how do you
skip their becoming the teachers the 14
year old is the mentor and Rosa Parks
was one of the first students and I
think that programs I watched the
program work this isn't just me biessing
here it's a great program I spent a day
up there and it's amazing what I saw and
just think the liberation for somebody
who's bedridden in a hospital or you
know or can't get around as much due to
their age somebody they can email that
student a new friendship
cross-generational also their relatives
and others so that particular program I
liked a great deal but what I wanted to
end with a story which involves judge
Damon Keith and a little bit and that is
one of the great moments in the 90s
there were some harsh moments here in
Detroit for Rosa Parks but one of the
really great moments was when Nelson
Mandela came to town and that was a
nineteen
90 Mandela had just got freed from
prison and America was gonna welcome him
and New York City through a ticker tape
parade and they lit up the Empire State
Building with the colors of the African
National Congress and they then went to
the White House I met George Bush then
went and dressed Congress Mandela the
next place Mandela wanted to go he said
I want to go to Detroit he want to go to
Troy he loved Joe Lewis it was his great
hero and it's the home of Rosa Parks
that's what he said Mandela yet didn't
really get back in the full way at that
point Jesse Jackson knew he said that
and the Planning Committee here in
Detroit had made an oversight that they
never got a official invitation or
invited Rosa Parks to they welcoming of
Mandela at the airport here and even a
few days before and Mandela's arrival
there's no room for Rosa Parks
now mrs. parks being a graduate of miss
white school for girls saying knowing
etiquette so Elsa I wasn't invited
they don't you know I shouldn't be there
Oh Mandela won't know me and if they
wanted me there I should I would have
been there I would have been asked and
Elaine had the good sense to to bring in
Judge Keith there's a longtime friend of
Rosa Parks and he is somebody who could
basically say to her and I don't mean to
put words in your mouth but something to
you know hush up Rose you're coming I'm
getting it every few people could talk
to her that way I think he can and said
you're getting you there of anybody on
this planet should be in Detroit when he
rised in the receiving line in the very
front it's Rosa Parks
so as they went there Elaine and and
Judge Keith and they got Rosa Parks in
the car and they got her there and
there's a crowd a mob scene and she's
keep saying he's not gonna know me and
all of this it's you know oh gosh I
shouldn't be here
she got towards the front of the
receiving line in Mandela's plane lands
and people are screaming for Swahili
word of power and there's a brisk
t-shirt vendor selling Mandela t-shirts
and Mandela gets off the plane and when
he's with him gives the big wave and the
crowds cheering and comes off and starts
walking down the tarmac and then he
stops in front and his eyes fix and
there's Rosa Parks and his his jaw drops
in his eyes water up with tears and he
stares at her and just in a very quiet
way which got louder just said Rosa
Parks Rosa Parks Rosa Parks Rosa Parks
Rosa Parks and they went and they hugged
and kissed and in that embrace the
American civil rights movement and the
anti-apartheid movement in South Africa
were intertwined and it was one of the
great redemptive moments of the American
Century thank
[Applause]
you're gonna accept the questions now
before we mr. Brinkley accepts question
you know his lovely wife is here mr.
Brinkley would you please stand I'd like
for this audience to see I wanted have a
few people if I could just I didn't want
to do it at the beginning and overload
us for the few people that we must
mention and we have a very special guest
in the front row and that's Matt Dawson
but I recently I gave a commencement
speech at Louisiana State University's
Sharif port and that just got an
honorary Doctorate but he's work he left
he left Louisiana for Detroit has worked
at the Ford Motor Company for years on
the assembly line or working in the
Rouge factories there he's now a
forklift driver but he started saving
all of his money working double-time
over a day sometimes seven days a week
got all this extra and then lived a
frugal life in many ways and and put
invested his money very wisely and is
amassed a bit of a fortune which he has
continues though to work as the fork
lifter even with this money and he
writes checks out to young people so
they can go to college I know for a fact
that he's given for example Wayne State
recently $600,000 there'll be another
2000 coming this October and
[Applause]
[Applause]
and he's continuing to give shreveport
where his in honor of his family and his
mother and things down there giving some
I know he's just giving them four
hundred thousand I want to give and
reveal all your money amounts but point
is he's just as great philanthropic
worth he's a huge admirer of Rosa Parks
and we're really pleased she came so
thank you so much again and then this
book is dedicated to a group of women
and two of them are here and that is
Elaine Steele who I again want to thank
but also age Leonards who introduced me
to elites and H could you stand for a
minute please and H is also one of mrs.
parks is truly great friends and
whenever Rosa Parks comes to comes to
Washington she stays that her wonderful
home there and does many things than in
that regard
oh very good
well this the I've just told Sylvester
juniors here when I thought I'd like to
do since with we but if we can bring a
microphone down for the for a Q&A is
somebody here with a portable mic where
they you do you have the movie mic could
we just have the family stand up I know
Sylvester Jr's here now but the family
of Rosa Parks stand firm and it just
introduce yourselves to all of us into
America so we can know know you a little
bit or at least get start getting
acquainted with you what's what's your
name okay thank you so much for coming
very often I write about Sylvester in
the books um and I I'm embarrassing I
was calling relatives at weird hours
here in Detroit saying you know I'm a
historian that's due pardon
I think at first year were very very
very helpful and I appreciate that I was
asking him things like the dimensions of
the house or what kind of vegetables
Sylvester would you know you're you know
mean real questions like what kind of
garden and what kind of food and did you
know in and then yeah they said with 13
children and Sylvester is earning a
living and feeding 13 children out and
kid the rest of the family here just
introduced themselves went to stand up I
noticed a cluster here Jack Cole Z Rosa
Custer from Montgomery Alabama
I'm Diane Williamson mistress in or or
our young people we let the one in
sleeping continue but they we a moment
one is standing up so what
she's your what aunty roses your aunty
well very good in what's your name your
cousin will core thank you for coming
you are that you are the future so I
have everything so thank you
[Applause]
is there someone else I get over all the
family it's a little harder so it's a
great honor and a little little daunting
to have so many of the family here and I
really appreciate it means after you
work hard in a book like that for you to
come out and listen to me I truly
appreciate it so thank you all and I
also want to thank Willis Edwards who
and I won't tell all the things we'll as
it does or his the many hats he wears
and the things that he does to make
America in the world remember the the
why we need to pay honor and respect to
Rosa Parks so instead of telling you all
that I will simply let's give him a
round of applause because he's just been
named the the n-double-a-cp National
Board he's remember the direct National
Board of the n-double a-c-p now he's
just was
[Applause]
well I went on too long I believe but I
really appreciate you all there will be
I'll be doing a book signing oh well
it's just when they tell about the
Congressional Gold Medal in the ceremony
at the at the Rotunda and the white and
the Capitol and I stayed went over two
H's for a brunch and they introduced my
Spence you got to meet mrs. parks and
many other limit up who's who of
everybody in the world that one it was
there and got to go to the very front
they allow me to come with them to sit
at the very front at the Capitol and
watch but mrs. Parkes got her
Congressional Gold Medal
Bill Clinton making President Clinton
making the the presentation and that's
one of the really rare great honors and
it was again a long overdue honor I went
and asked I got curious as this is
reporter in me I saw some of these
Republican senators who are always
voting against affirmative action and in
and are against the civil against civil
rights basically in various guys and all
I was shocked to see all of them said no
this was so great
this is great except Strom Thurmond he
didn't let us down I said this I said
senator Thurmond do you think this this
Congressional Gold Medal is long overdue
he's I wouldn't say that I don't think
it's long overdue at all and and so
there's still some of that there but I
think at this stage Rosa Parks has been
just adopted by the world as as not just
a mother of civil rights movement at
just one of the great figures of world
history and we'll all be gone we're all
be gone and people are gonna be talking
about Rosa Parks thank you
[Applause]
Douglas Brinkley is a professor of
history and director of the Eisenhower
Center at the University of New Orleans
this latest book is part of the penguin
live series of short biographies
published by Viking biography on book TV
can be seen